hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to zombie night terror
now we're gonna be continuing our
rampage of destruction and just judging
by the toolbar down here there seems to
be a lot of other things that we can do
there's like a claw type thing a big ol
hulking monstrosity
explosions speed spit sonic boom and
what I can only assume is a Hadouken or
a command mail wave but either way
there's a lot more depth to this game
and I can't wait to get to it but first
I gotta get through this game and see if
I can figure out how to do this but I
believe if I'm gonna do this I gotta go
this way first Hey
No there's a guy with a baton yeah that
guy's awfully confused we could the guy
ran screaming about zombies and then
suddenly this guy grew a giant pulsating
ball sack is that guy have a shotgun I'm
pretty sure that guy is a shotgun so I
want to take him out I don't know my
guys can probably can whoa what the hell
dude dude calm down it's okay how much
how much damn is it Wow
oh my god that got to that's okay didn't
do that much okay why are we trying to
bash down that wall dude seems like dude
you okay you all right you seem to be
undergoing some stress whoa Oh God
Oh to lady didn't even get one hit off
well they're dead
well your dad you should have moved okay
sorry the amination woooo explode hell
yes
what explode oh I know what to do okay
so I gotta wait until there's like one
oh jeez that's a big explosion radius Oh
why are they all group job oh what a
load of bullcrap
yeah I got speed through this what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna make them go down
except for one of them yeah okay that's
three of them but you know what I'll
take the risk sorry buddy you're uh we
just got your friends with you oh my god
that was horrifying I gotta do that
again
ah [ __ ] dude we're gonna do that how
many times oh Jesus
all right hang on cops
let's go jeez uh oh oh oh oh that's a
lot of gunfire for not allah god damnit
you made me miss Mike what the hell is
happening here guys got the guys got
guys guys guys guys I mean as
entertaining as that is you made me miss
my opportunity here so I Oh God
that's not the right way I'm a trekker
hey Kevin did okay that was good enough
all right get back over there no don't
do that oh okay go down here no jeez
once they're down there there's really
no shaking this one well okay this guy's
a straggler though so I'm gonna try to
get him good all right so uh no probably
walking into the hailstorm of gunfire
probably wouldn't be a good idea but
they don't seem to be able to hit
anything so maybe it wouldn't be too bad
but it just pushed him aside it didn't
even kill the guy that's nice very nice
I know I know I have one of those I'm
not gonna be
okay you stupid human pieces of crap
what oh oh oh Jesus that oh why why what
why did they suddenly turn into human
are zombies I didn't make any sense at
all alrighty then what are you doing
I'll leave that poor guy alone I think
you can miss okay bash down this door -
- oh god it's so vicious Jesus that's
like one of my worst things in any movie
or like for horror thing like that if a
character dies and they explode like
that
oh I can't stand it it's awful oh jeez
sorry dude Wow Wow
oh I'm sorry alright you know what just
for just for shits and giggles you guys
are gonna have a good time
I mean not a good time
oh sorry sorry lady wow I really I
really didn't do you a favor there lady
did I all right dude is that your van
we're gonna beat the [ __ ] out of your
van dude no parking completed I didn't
even know what the I didn't even know
what the extra challenge was I just did
it anyway oops oh boy
we're going into the basement I'll try
to do this one a bit more okay so it
just pushes the other zombies away it
doesn't necessarily blow them up which
is awful I don't have enough DNA for
this I don't get more DNA oh I got I got
no not you not you a little bit of you
everywhere earn you okay that's good
it's gonna burn you to get you out of
the way they're giant explosions oh I
wonder what they could have man look
supposing that it reaches here we're
perfectly safe oh sure I'm sure you okay
so how could I get explosions to reach
all the way up there oh geez okay so I
got DNA for an overlord oh maybe I can
make an overlord explode and it would be
an even bigger piece of damage is that
it would be I am correct Oh
oh you hear that one [ __ ] and then he
just goes back to work oh jeez well
frankly you deserve that one why do I
love this game would you say to find a
way out of the underground passage
subway Massacre kill every human do I
want to do that and that's a lot of
humans where are they gonna go oh it's a
sprawling level wait who's that zombies
over there where did you guys come from
well do something your dicks
alright fine then I'll make my way bow
that's a lot of zombies okay um we need
an overlord and we need to burn you and
okay try that you go that way alright
and then oh alright got that guy I don't
think we actually needed to do all of
that but you know I'm an overachiever ah
we need to put an overlord over here
guys what's up it's dangerous alright so
what we need to not do all we need to
have another Overlord up top because
it's too much much up there
oh no wait no this is good BAM okay
then that guy's gonna bash open that one
and then hang on let me just wait guys
wake up Bert okay that guy's dead what's
the trouble
alien invasion oh that guy's on the
toilet okay so oh all right so now this
guy goes way it's guy goes way hey what
do you think you're doing where do you
think you're going Bubba alright so
they're going that way ah I must have
messed something up there
maybe not that would take a lot of
explosions but I do like explosions
alrighty then so do I want to go down go
down
since going up would take far too long
and I've already missed out on my
overachiever status boy oh hi Oh No oh
that's not good oh that's the opposite
of good Oh what was I thinking
Oh God I [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up I [ __ ]
it oh jeez they're all dead
- yep I [ __ ] it I [ __ ] it I [ __ ]
it it wasn't anyone that stopped me I
stopped myself
I [ __ ] all right take you we're going
going fast mode here cuz I can think
with my brain so I need to burn you no
no I need to know I don't need to
overlord I just need to blow you up both
okay loose key this guy hey oh good wait
that's enough that guy oh jesus no oh
god no you guys didn't see anything
nothing happened there nothing went
wrong everything was fine don't worry
about an error okay so we need to go we
need to send one guy over that way with
malenky maybe two and then the rest go
up caboose key now that they got that
all unlock oh no I'm sorry lady I'm
really sorry about that
I'm sorry about that you just wanna get
all jeez I'm sorry about that
okay wait they can't open that door huh
how about a little bit of a shabu ski
well that didn't do [ __ ] did it why is
that door impenetrable is it
impenetrable - Wow oh my god what the
hell happened there
alrighty then but maybe from below you
wouldn't like to be alone oh hey maybe I
don't know about how about this I don't
have enough DNA are you boot gimme gimme
yeah that's enough come on with your
[ __ ] is not gonna work is it alright
fine then screw you and screw your face
okay so I don't know how to kill
everybody just yet I don't have that
ability
alright so boom and then if my entire
team could get over here in a bit of a
skedaddle e hurry you know not leave me
in the lurch and just making everybody
wait on you even though you're in fast
forward motion and you should be doing
this correctly but now we're back into
the thick of it okay
now we goddamn it one more really boesky
okay so now I do not blow up that area
where those do I go okay so but if I'm
not mistaken I need to definitely have a
bigger explosion but I'm running out of
zombies here so I'm gonna have you right
there all right and then I get this guy
oh yes
oh no well that's not what I wanted how
did that do that now that's what I call
a perfect gas well that's that's that's
lovely
okay well I am only a little bit
confused here well that's not good okay
I think maybe the problem was this
security camera here like they they were
watching that and maybe that triggered
some additional security measures over
there but I'm not a hundred percent sure
about that so either way that guy's
gotta go sorry buddy you did you did
real good but you know I gotta make
progress here
so I'm just gonna forgo trying to kill
those guys because I just don't think
that's gonna work and then when I come
down here literally what else do I do
that guy gets scared but there's really
nothing to that one and there's
explodable walls over here but not up
there and then there's no way to get
down there in a safe manner that's not a
global wall okay so the big thing is
this door here that's unblown anyway
because that's the same as this door and
I've tried to blow that one up so even
if I got there it wouldn't make a lot of
sense for me the only problem is I can't
fall down here this is the death traps
so I've got to go down here like I have
to look it's pause this for a second
here I have to go down here somehow
and then can't blow this up is that
'blow-up-able I mean I don't have a lot
of DNA to spare exactly but I just want
to like you know see if that is then
maybe no it is not okay that's weird but
either way the only way whoa oh that's
how you do it that's right if they die
oh I forgot about that
oh my god I am just an idiot okay so if
I go through here have this key and then
this guy oh oh oh that didn't do
anything because they did oh but he's
alive but he is alive sorry to drop in
on you guys
sorry you having a good time over here
you having a good time I bet you're not
all right and then that guy dies and
then this guy I need him blown up in the
right direction that was not the right
direction okay but now this guy right
here can post up and be the super blower
let me just get some DNA here uno dos Oh
Tracy oh I'm out of ruble feels good
sugar sugar and then I've got this guy
to go I'm so sorry about that I'm so
sorry
and then I've got all these guys that I
don't really need anymore because
they're not helping people my endeavor
here and then this guy goes kerfuffle
uncle and Fanny's out of here I rescued
that guy the only other question is I
guess it could have blown that up but I
only had one guy up there but then I
would have had two and they would have
been able to go over there but then they
might have fallen through so I needed to
make sure that would've been a big
explosion enough bodies around I got I'm
good so we got this on lock so I really
like this I've know I said that a lot
after I died prostate it's too much now
but I just I like it a lot I don't know
how I would have gotten everybody I
would have taken a lot of really really
close hey boss is Miguel down the
entrance looks like some customers found
our address no refunds we got the best
[ __ ] in town they don't like it too bad
get rid of them and don't call me back
until it's sorted what the [ __ ] am I
paying you for
I don't know I don't know what you're
paying all right then well that's a
pretty sturdy defense right up until I
make them explode so I gotta kill all
the guns huh hey my guys dude I need to
get there eventually gosh I'm not gonna
be able to get it oh my goodness
my poor zombies how am I gonna be able
to do this okay oh I know it I'm gonna
okay I'm gonna restart this because I
bet I know what I need to do I need to
get them all in a bunch because they
need to go quick so you need to hold
them off I'm gonna burn these guys cuz I
want the do I didn't need to be in any
way but either way I'm gonna burn those
guys we're gonna get a whole bunch of
people here then we're gonna go in an
onslaught oh and also I'm gonna blow
that up with this guy already sure
that'll reach up that'll reach I'll blow
that up
I'll get that donut and we'll go over
there we'll all bleed them up with our
fists bang them good it'll be great it's
gonna be great don't worry about it
any minute now all right that's enough
probably we got it right so then you owe
your overcome with virus you don't even
try you're done okay I don't think we're
gonna be that guy is thank you
yes yes oh jeez well don't go that way
good don't think that guy's missing also
good thing that guy's dead oh I should
have gotten that guy up top and then I
would have been able to keep going ah
III [ __ ] that one up but that's okay
alright so these guys are gonna go there
they're gonna get that guy you're gonna
break this door down you're gonna blow
up they're gonna break that barricade
but not before you die a whole lot
apparently oh jeez I could have done
that better okay so we got that you got
that there so I don't want to I don't
want to trigger that we could do is get
this
guy yeah that's more like it
okay now we need to go nope some need to
go down send me to go up okay okay
okay those guys going that way good what
boots keep Hey
come on now be nice dang it alright so
now get a whole horde of them coming
what I could do could feed to this one
oh no it's a now all right whoa there
whoa whoa not yet not yet team squadron
now like I got matched they're doing
their thing we got our explosive over
there so if I get this guy close enough
so we're gonna we're gonna have
ourselves a little party here you boys
ready go get him boys green means go
green means go
green means murder them dead whoa oh hey
face um Oh God come on oh come on oh
jeez that's there we go that's more like
it
eat that guy all right that's good
you're doing good not doing that good
how are these guys able to fight you
that badly
okay good they're dead down so we got
one more of these things I need to kill
the Gunners kill those guys
pretty sure we're gonna be able to do
that but not yet oh jeez
how are we gonna get down there oh I
have another one these things
what's going on buddy what's going on
friend what you okay you okay
Oh get him get him get him yes yes you
did great buddy
you are the best now we won't even hit
that landmine but just oh god no wait no
no don't do that yeah everybody's
skipping over it okay we're okay we're
okay we're okay
Oh No Alert red alert we've been there
in a bunch
yeah mmmm bad thing oh that was dumb of
that guy okay so now you can come over
even though you're gonna die
instantaneously okay oh you did
those are my zombie friends bring me the
chemist his new [ __ ] sucks I'm gonna
lose my shirt if he keeps killing my
customers oh I paid good money for the
show oh that's good I mean it's bad for
the show
oh Jesus God always comes out of nowhere
oh I didn't kill all the guns oh I guess
if I would have infected those guys at
the end I didn't know about the fire at
that point oh well you live and learn
and then you get loves so either way I
think that's all the time I got for this
episode I'm really oh my god well going
into the crypts of the underworld here
boys what's that is that piss do I get
some zombie piss I hope I do oh these
guys are messed up too oh that's cool I
also love do you notice the little
details of how the light actually
affects the little pixelated figures
here the the pixelated figures have
lighting effects on them how cool is
that and how minut of a detail is that
but how nice is it that is there oh the
TV six six nine you guys are all wrong -
either way I'm all out of time for this
one but thank you again everybody so
much for watching I can't wait to play
more of this very soon which I'm gonna
do maybe you think so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]